A plane carrying Wagner group leader Yevgeni Prasin crashed northwest of
Moscow on Wednesday.
Prasin and nine other people were killed.
According to Russian authorities,
Wagner affiliated social media channels claim the plane was shot down by Russian air
defenses.
The incident marks an abrupt end to two months of speculation and mystery surrounding
Pogo's whereabouts and his status in Putin's inner circle.
Here's how we arrived at this moment
on June 23 and 24 Prasin led a mutiny against the Russian government
eventually capturing a military headquarters in the city of Rostov
and marching a column of Wagner fighters toward Moscow.
But the rebellion ended almost as quickly as it started when Pergo negotiated a deal
with Putin that granted him immunity from prosecution if he went into exile in
Belarus
left Rostov to applause and has appeared
only a handful of times since after using the war in Ukraine to
build an increasingly public profile.
Persian's social media presence suddenly went dark.
Then on June 29 th five days after the mutiny despite his negotiated
exile,
Russian media published photos claiming to show Prasin in ST Petersburg.
Putin later said he had met with Prasin on that day to discuss Wagar group's future.
Then in late June and into July flight tracking data showed Pogo's jet
taking trips between Russia and Belarus as satellite images confirmed the
construction of a new Wagner camp there in mid July.
Wagner's social media channels published a photo claiming to show Pergo in a tent at Wagner's
new Belarusian camp suggesting the group's transition was proceeding as planned
on July 19.
Th the first video of Prasin since the mutiny emerged.
Wagner's social media channels published a video claiming to show Pra Gozin and Wagner commander
Dmitry Udin speaking to Wagner fighters.
In his speech,
Prasin discusses Wagner's new role training the Belarusian military and pledges a renewed
focus
for the shave we order in here.
No,
a week later,
African leaders assembled in ST Petersburg for the Russia Africa summit.
Wagner social media posted photos of Pergo at the summit meeting with representatives from the Central
African Republic and African media outlets
on August 21st.
Wagner group continued to signal its focus on Africa.
Wagner's telegram channel has published a video of Prasin in which he claims to be in Africa and
shares a recruiting message.
Just two days later,
Pogo's plane was shot down